what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alva
John Humphrey we are gonna watch
stranger things season 3 episode 2
excited to check this out go ahead and
watch our episode 1 reaction if you can
before we go into that just wanted to
give a reminder we are only uploading
these one day at a time so if you can go
ahead subscribe and click that
notification bell that way you could be
notified every time when our bids is out
that would be great for this whole spiel
before but I'm gonna say it again just
in case thank you to Eric over at nerd
product for editing these reaction
highlights for us you too only allows
for 10 minutes maximum worth of reaction
footage to be included in here so our
stream along for stranger things all
going over at our patreon page over
there we do scream along for several
shows that includes hunting a hill house
John did all that Cobra Kai season 2
Gotham and we do other shows that have
stream alongs as well as reaction
highlights included and those are my
hero academia one punch man Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood attack on Titan
and supernatural so go over to our
patreon page as soon as you can thanks
again to Eric for editing this he's done
work for people like Eamon snow aqus on
the movie trivia Schmo down has his own
podcast on YouTube her podcast or fan so
give the guy fall it's a great dude
let's get to it finally
we'll see them in motel door I'll be
ready
oh not okay it's better be the primary
focus of the show oh don't mess around
with Jim I'll see you at set but clean
that [ __ ] up if there's no coincidences
and stranger things I really mean one of
the girls came running read lunch today
I've been having some
men cannot handle yes yes girl yes yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
are they like how all the non
supernatural stuff is so
[Music]
you soon
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
because use an entirely different
alphabet than we did I'm fluent in four
languages disease dead rats oh yeah I
[Music]
got 400 rats
who here is yeah oh [ __ ] thanks for
coming by
That's not me hmm it's just good
old-fashioned American capitalist
American right I agree if if they had a
permit at the end of the day that's all
the voters will remember but I can't
think going on out there
if you don't mind he's really having fun
with this roll please just do your job
yeah sure go back
[Music]
America we should go to the mall tonight
and hang around all the teenagers yeah
good like Rory game you just try things
on does it spark joy like yeah yeah not
hot not like you find yourself girl
there's only five library books at a
time yay
[Music]
[Music]
no poor rat time
that hell is happening oh whoa oh [ __ ]
Oh give it away
oh the actually hurt her
[Music]
and I still react that way this sounds
it Agha well this is you know like
Europe nice out your approve it
what is it they have a lot of money or
something make it explode headaches make
it explode yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
we're only two episodes in and they
break awkward when Maxim Lucas so glad
that cop gets to be enough in here this
is no longer in the Marvel Netflix shows
[Music]
Russia
[Music]
she's looking at magnets how do they
work
[Music]
everyone's against it up this season
and it looks so suave you can't see it
but it's there
I assure you our very own Clark fires
electromagnetic field pretty neato huh
yeah in order to reach your house in
downtown pass 17 billions of volts of
electricity and cost tens of millions of
dollars and it would mean Russians -
operated Russians - polio in 53 listen
just for kicks let's entertain the
possibility that it's a secret Russian
transmission what do you think they were
going to say IRA warheads correct
[Music]
it's a song yeah the music Steve
contributed there under the ball didn't
come from Russia
here
[Music]
screw the election Oh al
[Music]
[Music]
oh so sick of this sjw crap be there
pretty great season so far guys Olivia
what do you think of the episode what
you'd like once again really enjoyed the
tone of this episode I love the human
thing like I said I am like the first
episode I prefer the focusing on the
relationships and building up to the
supernatural elements we're just
throwing it in our faces which I felt
like last season had a lot of and you
just get the subtle elements this is
pretty natural and this which is really
nice Billy you're kind of starting to
feel for him you starting to feel bad
for him you can see that struggle within
him when he tells that one woman you
know stay away from me when he has that
flash of killing her he does it to kind
of protect her so you can kind of see
that internal struggle I like those
overall themes of that internal struggle
with him you get to see 11 coming into
her own not being who Hopper wants her
to be or who mike wants her to be but
really learning who she is and she gets
that girl bonding time too so yeah I
really thought this was a very episode
they're kind of giving some of that
treatment to Nancy as well you know
having that juxtaposition of being
female journalist at a time like this I
know it's topia issue in the workplace
today but you know especially for the
times of 2010 I'm liking the Nancy's
portrayal I didn't really care for Nancy
and Jonathan that much in the last
season Jonathan seems to really be so
much more but it's only been two
episodes but he seems so much more of a
co-star and less of a supporting star
just within these two episodes alone by
now I finally would probably
more attention put on him yeah I don't
know if this has to do with the
controversial real life stuff he
encountered or they even thought he
might not be able to be in stranger
things season 3 caught at the airport
with drugs right okay cocaine I feel
like he's they've kind of taken him a
lot more of a backseat but who knows to
probably get more time to shine because
he's got so much to do in season one you
got plenty of doing too and then here
I'm like I kind of forget you were you
even existed well in season three it
seems like he's not part of two plot
lines anymore he's only part of one so
it's like wherever Nancy goes so goes
Jonathan he doesn't really have the
whole bonding with will now that Will's
back thing and yeah we're kind of fueled
the heart of his character for me in the
second seasons I do hope that he gets
something to do other than gawk at
extremely strange things seems like he's
here to mainly support Nancy's character
in this journey which is fine there's no
okay and also spreading around the focus
between different characters cuz again
to having binge this all in one like
rapid succession I can really feel the
kind of unfolding of all these
storylines and so a lot of it actually
makes some good sense to me and I like
even with Billy you know I think that
because he's such a dick in season two
and he's still kind of a dick in like
the first episode of you tries to
persuade Nancy's mom to cheat you know
with him and now we're getting into a
moment with him where he really doesn't
know what's going on with himself I
thought those sequences where he's kind
of losing it at the pool were really
effective it seems like he's headed down
a very sinister path but I'm hoping that
this path can again broaden him as a
character but also just the pairings
they have - I thought it was really fun
to get max and xi together I really like
the relationship that has grown between
Steve and dust and out of season 2 into
this and my favorite dynamic out of it
all yeah and I like that each season
thus far the dynamic of the group
changes every single pocket of the
ensemble goes through conflict and
different members scatter and so now it
seems like you have Lucas will and Mike
together Dustin's off on his own side
quest and things are kind of shaken
eleven so there's just a lot you know
that makes me excited to see where it's
gonna land and Steve does that a sister
who he works with that's the vibe I get
I thought I felt like that's a sister I
didn't really get romantic interest so
I'm like are they related or some yeah
she gets pulled into the craziness they
definitely got when she was like oh I've
ever liked her later or something it's
what I got and the way this show has let
certain things unfold I think I could
see that happening because like I
actually kind of like the way they
handle the messiness of the triangle
that was Nancy Jonathan and Steve now I
can see it being like yeah at first at
the outset I don't really think they
have romantic chemistry at the moment
because they're not suggesting it to me
but I think they definitely have
chemistry's characters again as Steve
got cooler the further he got pulled
into the craziness of Hopkins you know I
can also see that for her maybe yeah
they do a good job on their new
characters I'm loving how the show is
really excelling at making me forget
about supernatural stuff yeah I mean you
tune in for that that's the big exciting
thrilling gripping you know oh my god
moments when you're just invested in
some of like the fun and games and then
some just real life drama this whole
thing with Mike and 11:00 instantly
pretty get up so fast man but you know
you're teenagers the way the
decision-making is going and Mike lying
there haven't really made Mike out to be
a super likable guy he's fast couple
episodes he's just been very sneaky and
rebellious he's trying to do the right
thing but doesn't really know how to do
the right thing I guess I can actually
sort of relate to that department
because he's lying cuz he feels like he
asked a lie cuz Hopper was threatening
him but even then I felt like he was
incredibly rude to hopper I was like
yeah that's part of why I like the
dichotomy of them because his
relationship with hoppers more than just
you're the dad of the girl I'm dating
they have all this history before Hopper
officially adopted 11 they had this
whole other kind of
and relationships so I can actually see
why Mike wouldn't treat him with the
level of respect that you would normally
do with the father of a daughter they go
back they go way back and so it's such a
complicated dynamic already so it makes
sense to me but I think they're doing a
really good job of fleshing all this out
so far Mike and 11 are gonna get back
together right got it but my part with
that is it's so funny to watch all this
stuff happen and then even the things
with hopper trying to woo Joyce I I'm
liking the way that's playing out
because he's being direct about it he's
being straightforward I mean even though
he said it's not a date that's such a
line to do because she knows what he's
trying to do I like that he's really
trying this this season around because
the last couple seasons is so obvious
he's into her but he doesn't do much
about it and here he is right off the
bat he's really trying I'm wondering if
like these these layers of overdrinking
you know just alcoholism that's pretty
much what he's got going on if that's
really gonna come into play a little bit
more for his you know it's personal
journey I know it's a part of kind of
what makes him noodle charming easy
enough it feel what's funny thing about
movies and shows that sometimes you can
make the drunk like the really charming
character because what really it's like
no you actually has a struggle with
alcoholism that's going on the way he's
behaving at the restaurant and even
walking out going I'm the chief police I
can do whatever I want I'm wondering if
these personal journeys are gonna come
into play what I guess I'm why I'm
emphasizing so much their personal
journeys is because it seems like
whatever the supernatural incident when
we get more answers and we're starting
to see that more unfold I'm loving how
the first two episodes have spent so
much time honing in on how that will be
an external journey that will probably
help them overcome whatever personal
inner conflicts are currently having and
that's what I think the writing is doing
such a good job I'm doing I keep me in a
fast-paced entertaining some really
gripping stuff it's so personal yeah in
a way that doesn't feel clawing or feels
right you know it's like I actually add
about the characters and I actually care
about following up with them whether or
not there's any supernatural exactly I'm
not finding myself getting impatient
going once this shicken again like to
really start picking up steam because
when it happens it's still very
mysterious and gripping doesn't feel
repetitive but an expansion upon what
we've all learned about the upside-down
world so far but anyway we just watch
Epis
three let's get to it before we wrap
that up thank you guys for watching make
sure to subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell check us
out on patreon we've got all them
goodies over there I wanted to wrap this
up I said this last video put out a post
on our patreon page for those for a
pledge for the shower war tears say for
watching stranger things season 3 be put
in the lineup to get a shout out in one
of the 8 episodes first 8 people who
either hit the like letter a comment
something and the second person is a
very very new patron only been pledged
at the time of filming this less than 24
hours I sent him a couple messages cuz
you know I like to give my really
personal shoutouts Harmon deep sing I
think that's how you pronounce his name
it's flushed up here on screen now he
hasn't replied to anything I've said he
replied to the post but he hasn't
replied to anything I've said so in true
good old-fashioned greg alba style
looked up your name buddy and here's
what it means huge cut your name Harmon
deep it's giving you a desire for self
expression and for positions that allow
contact with people free from
restrictions and monotony and if that
was true you would have replied to me no
you know you're not living up to it I'm
being vigilant and watchful I saw you
pledged I messaged you and yeah you're
not they're not getting back to me
you got to live up to your name and your
last name it's a lot of things like lion
and hero an eminent person oh wow that's
that's pretty great well Harmon deep I
just wanted to say thank you for
pledging even if you don't happen to
watch this episode I'm glad that you
kept your card on file and hopefully you
don't ever read my messages and we don't
ever have to actually have long
exchanges back and forth don't and that
you just forget that your pledge to our
page until a year goes by before you
know it there's nothing you can do to
get a refund see what happens when you
don't reply I say stupid [ __ ] see you
guys